what's going to happen I'm really going
to end this before it's like when you
divide by zero good day good morning
hallelujah I'm so tired from yesterday
we are going right now I'm gonna get a
suit because I'm gonna be on television
and you have to wear a suit then no I'm
actually excited I just didn't bring one
coming here cuz I'm I forgot so it'll be
fun
you guys are coming along we're in
Beverly Hills this feels way too fancy I
don't know what I'm doing here
I'm crossing the street while vlogging
that's what I'm saying great alright
let's try on some suits cool holes a few
things that I think would be cool so
this is for you see you're probably a 38
tip number one okay yeah yes
suit number one I like this one
huh my suit number three this might be a
favorite all right
we picked a suit oh okay that took
literally like 30 minutes so we're going
to get some lunch and party hard
I'm so tired today yesterday was just so
crazy I'm going to fix my watch because
it's not working
there we go which one do you breast
prefer I kind of like cheap watches
because I always get bored of them
I just like changing them I don't know
what
my 10 wants to get a dress
I just want to go home and sleep
we're heading back I ended up buying a
bunch of stuff so it's okay
very fun day today so much happening yes
I feel like I'm hugg Disney hungover I'm
so tired okay so I'm about to record a
video on the computer I have not done
this since I started the vlogs
I'm nervous this is so weird
okay let's do this
how's it going bros amazing today we're
gonna play my game finally wow wow wow
wow I'm so [ __ ] pissed the recording
I did didn't work out I don't know the
file just doesn't work so I'm trying to
make it work on PC and for some reason
it's not work on PC like this is not my
computer so he makes everything so hard
when it's so simple to make videos at
home and I'm just like I just want to
Netflix and chill oh I'm so pissed off
I've been trying to get this game to
work been installing this forever like
what is what is this even plugged in to
it what is this what does this go salad
this computer runs on salad organic
salad now it's downloading Visual Studio
look how slow that is just look at that
what is this [ __ ] Ethernet cable
doing where is it going [ __ ] it's a
bread with a smiley face on it to be
somewhat productive I'm doing this
I feel like a machine yeah baby mmm
this vlog is my favorite blog out of all
the blogs I get to watch kids do boring
[ __ ] okay my shooting star smile I'm
gonna see if I can surprise them
ah are you okay with bad timing
okay we're waiting for before the shoot
but we're also having a lot of fun yes I
just found it legend of the brofist so
guys what's your review of the game it's
the worst game I've ever questioned it's
the worst game we've ever played another
quality day on the shoot oh my god it
smells so much how's the gun bros is
beer
what another paragraph what is good and
hey these guys have been here since 2:00
and it's what time is it 9:30 9:30 thank
you so much this guy yeah worth it yes
and brofist here should be it should be
really interesting really interesting I
wanna see you bro piss yourself
what's gonna happen I'm the world's
gonna end this before it's like when you
divide by zero this is the oldest house
all the top of LVM that's cool
so does people live here yeah really oh
no no not anymore
but you can't go in there mirror
changing people oh no I can get that for
the blog one of the bedrooms and it's
got a jacket it's so creepy
I shot here on a horror movie watch this
that's this door oh that's the door
that's the door that's this room [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] cool mmm
we're creepy whoa this is super scary
dude oh my god dude I'd be terrified if
I was up here dude I came out to scout
this location yeah a little thing with
the Ouija board and all that oh and they
leave it now here for I don't know it
may be just a creepy voice smells weird
yeah ooh just gets creepier oh [ __ ] this
why am I just going here I would not go
down here alone
and come out here check this out [ __ ]
this is so creepy
check the Headroom oh no an actual uh I
really don't want that what is this it's
the exit oh yeah dude this is creep me
out I really want to get out of it
different advice widow's bug we're done
for today I'm stopping my CVS because I
wanted to get Marzia something so for
those of you who didn't know so awkward
is listed in my face we have X a lottle
a friend of ours is taking care of the
hugs and the axolotls while we're away
but the aquarium broke
apparently tonight and it's taken March
day like every day an hour to prepare
the aquarium because it needs to get the
cycle of a bacteria going it doesn't
matter the aquarium broke and we're
going to be away next month so we're not
going to be able to take care of them so
we're gonna have to get give them away
or something and Marcie's super upset
about it because she worked so hard to
get for them and she's singin care of
them and I feel so bad so that's why I
wanted to cheer her up at least a little
bit so yes
be nice to Marcia say something nice to
her and I'm gonna end the vlog here
thank you for watching had another this
is the last day of the shoot actually
and I'm really really sad it's over but
this has been so much fun I had like the
time of my life I'm so glad I did this
and it's thanks to you bros that I can
do is awesome stuff like this
so we're going to end this with a kiss
in public it's going to be awkward it's
gonna be weird but let's Jewish we're
gonna Disneyland
everyone's excited
my boyfriend is buying me again you're
welcome darling